[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ختم
مباركه
[موسيقى]
شام استقلال
مبارك وحسن
[موسيقى]
محترمون ندعو الجميع للاستفاده من عفو
القائد الاعلى الكل سواسيه جنرال وزير
رئيس البرلمان اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ ورؤساء
البلديات اي شخص نفتح لهم ابواب امارتنا
الاسلاميه يجب ان نتحد لاعاده بناء بلدنا
لن ندمر افغانستان بسبب مسائل ماليه دنيئه
لسنا اعداء لبعضنا داخل الوطن
[موسيقى]
هذه الوجوه لم يرد لها ان ترى لم تكن هناك
رغبه في الاستماع الى كلامها وافغانستان
التي بناها الغرب انهارت مثل بيت من ورق
20 عاما من الحرب كلفت اكثر من تريليوني
دولار انفقتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وخلفت اكثر من
176,000 قتيل
[موسيقى]
عندما ترى هذه الكلفه البشريه لا يمكن
وصلها الا بالماساه هناك الكثير من الدروس
لنتعلمها لكن السؤال هل سنتعلم فعلا
في الخامس عشر من اغسطس 2021
استعادت حركه طالبان السلطه في افغانستان
بعد خروجهم من مخابئهم اكتشف اليافعون من
طالبان عاصمتهم كابل فيما استعاد قدماء
المحاربين مناصبهم القياديه من اجل فهم
حقيقي لهذه العوده نحتاج الى استعاده بعض
الذكريات والقاء نظره على بدايات طالبان
قبل 30 عاما
سبب انضمامنا الى مقاتل طالبان كان انعدام
الامن في البلاد بسبب الحرب الاهليه
المستعره فيها لم تتح لنا الفرصه لنعيش
حياه طبيعيه وهادئه كان هناك الكثير من
القتال ولم يكن بمقدور احد ان يعيش في
سلام من جاء احساس امنات نابوت
في مواجهه هذا العنف اختار الغرب تجاهل
الموضوع ورغم ذلك توفرت لنا مثل هذه الصور
التي التقطها قله من الصحفيين الشجعان كان
ذلك في عام 1992
وكانت الفصائل تقاتل بعضها من اجل السلطه
هؤلاء الرجال كانوا ابطالا سلحتهم
الولايات المتحده بهدف دحر الغزاه
الصافيات لكنهم الان وقد باتوا غير
مستعدين للتوافق بعد التحرير ينشرون
الفوضى في العاصمه الافغانيه
ولدت في كابول لقد تاذيت كثيرا
جرحت في العمق تلك الذكريات لا تزال
تؤلمني كانت مدينه للاشباح
بعد الرابعه عصرا كانت الكلاب تتجول
كلاب اعتادت نهشه اجساد البشر ولحومهم
باريس
فلاش
كان الناس يمشون كالاشباح مجرد هياكل
عظميه تمشي بالكاد يمكنك ان ترى شيئا من
الحياه في اعينهم وعلى ملامحهم
اربعه اعوام من القتال ما زالت عصيه عن
النسيان مثل اسماء القاده انذاك
احمد شاه مسعود قلب الدين حكمه يار عبد
الرشيد دستوم اسماعيل خان
عبد رب الرسول سياف
سواء كانوا قاده او زعماء دينيين او
حزبيين او زعماء قبائل فقد اصبحوا جميعا
ولاسباب وجيهه يعرفون باسم امراء الحرب
فيما النساء كنا غنائم حرب
اختطاف تجاوزوا ازدواج اجبوري
تعددت عمليات الاختطاف والاغتصاب والزواج
القصري كانت فتاه صغيره تسكن في مجمع
الشقق السكنيه الذي عشت فيه بكابل جاءت
مجموعه من الرجال الاختطافها واغتصابها
امرتها جدتها بالقفز من النافذه وهكذا
فعلت رمت بنفسها من الطابق السادس وبقي
جثمانها هناك طيله يومين وليلتين لم يجرؤ
احد على نقله نساء كثيرات بل يمكنني القول
جيل كامل من النساء كنا ضحايا مثل هذا
العنف
في جنوب افغانستان قام عدد لا يحصى من
الزعماء الصغار وجميعهم منسيون الان
بتسويه قندهار وما حولها بالارض ومن رحم
هذه الفوضى ولدت حركه طالبان في عام
1994 تركوا مدارسهم القرانيه لاجل استعاده
النظام وسياده القانون هذه الصور المبكره
لا تعطي انطباعا كافيا عن حجم هذه الحركه
كان هناك عدد هائل من مقاتل طالبان
انتفضوا من الارياف ومن مخيمات اللاجئين
في باكستان المجاوره تلك الباقيه من ارث
الحرب السابقه
تحسين ودوران عالم ميكو كنت طالبا اتعلم
من اساتذه ومما يكبرني سنا وكان واجبا
علينا ان نتحرك لان فقراءنا كانوا يتعرضون
للظلم وصل الظلم حدا ما كان ممكنا معه
الاستمرار في الجلوس ببساطه وتفرجوا على
ما كان يحدث لذلك نفذنا اوامر قائدنا
الملا محمد عمر رحمه الله والذي لولاه
لاكتفينا باتمام تعليمنا
سيطرت حركه طالبان على معظم ارجاء البلاد
وورث معها اسامه بن لادن ومن حوله من
المجاهدين الذين قدموا من جهات العالم
الاربعه هذه هي القصه المنسيه زعيم تنظيم
القاعده لم يستقبل من قبل طالبان وانما من
قبل امراء الحرب في شرق افغانستان وكان
ذلك قبل ان تتولى الحركه مقاليد السلطه في
البلاد في عام
1996 استورد طالبان على العاصمه كابل
وقدمت لها القاعده بيعه الولاء لقد حمت
الحركه الناس من امراء الحرب
برحيلهم لقد تم طردهم على ايدي طالبان
لاسباب وجيها لم يكن ما فعلته طالبا سيئا
ساخبرك كافاني وكائسان لم يكن كل ما فعلته
طالبان سيئا
ابتعدت الحرب عن المدن ووضع الطالبان حدا
لكافه عمليات الاغتصاب والاعتداء الجنسي
والزواج القصري والاختطاف
ازالوا ذلك البلاء عن النسوه وانهوا ذلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فرض الطالبان نظاما عد شديد التزمت ما
اثار غضب العالم باسره اختفت النساء عن
الانظار واستبعدن من الحياه العامه
والتوظيف والتعليم لقد تابع الغرب هذه
التطورات دون ان يفهم انها كانت الثمن
لاستعاده السلام شكل الامر صدمه لسكان
المدن فبعد 15 عاما من الشيوعيه والحرب
الاهليه وجدوا انفسهم في مواجهه التشدد
المفروض من مواطنيهم
حركه طالبان من مجموعه من الناس
التقليديين لم يقدموا اي جديد لهذا البلد
ما كانوا يتحدثون عنه الشريعه الاسلاميه
القوانين الاسلاميه كان موجودا في هذا
البلد منذ اكثر من الف عام لان افغانستان
لم تكن قط مستعمره لاي امبراطوريه ولم
يسبق لها ان جربت ايه قوانين بريطانيه او
فرنسيه او ايطاليه او اي قوانين اخرى
حكم الطالبان افغانستان بقبضه من حديد
لمده خمس سنوات لكن الاوضاع انقلبت راسا
على عقب في الجانب الاخر من العالم
في الحادي عشر من سبتمبر 2001 هاجم تنظيم
القاعده امريكا على اراضيها
لم تستوعب امريكا ما حدث فسعت للانتقام
[تصفيق]
اسامه
في افغانستان رفض البيت الابيض تفاوض مع
طالبان وتعمد ربط النظام الافغاني
بالمنظمه الاجنبيه الغامضه على الرغم من
الاصوات المعارضه
في وكاله الاستخبارات كانت هناك الكثير من
النقاشات في هذه اللحظه الاولى هل علينا
استهداف طالبان
يومها راى البعض انه لا ينبغي لنا ذلك لان
المعلومات المتوفره لنا كانت تقول صحيح ان
طالبان يلعبون دور المضيف للقاعده لكنهم
في الحقيقه لم يعلموا شيئا عن الحادي عشر
من سبتمبر ولا عنصر واحد من طالبان متورط
في ذلك العمل الارهابي
ين
[موسيقى]
في اكتوبر 2001 ارادت امريكا ان تضرب
بسرعه وبقوه فعلت ذلك عن طريق الجو والهدف
كان تدمير القاعده ونظام طالبان لكنها لم
تلزم قواتها بالقتال في افغانستان
لقد استخدمت وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه امراء الحرب للقتال على الارض
هؤلاء انفسهم الذين مزقوا البلاد قبل ست
سنوات
[موسيقى]
عندما جاء الامريكيون وجدوا امراء حرب
ساخطين وعندما قلنا لهم سنعطيكم اسلحه
تمكنكم من اعاده تشكيل ميليشياتكم اجابوا
على الفور موافقون سنفعل ما تريدون المهم
ان تتركونا نعود امراء حرب مره اخرى
المخابرات المركزيه وقالوا لي هذا سيجلب
مستقبلا مشرقا لافغانستان سناتي بحشد هائل
لهزيمه اعدائكم طالبان والقاعده اكبر جيش
في العالم اكبر اقتصاد في العالم جاء الي
يسالني ما العمل بدا الامر وكاننا صرنا
جميعا الرجل العنكبوت
[موسيقى]
طالبات
تنهز طالبان من شمال وغربي ووسط افغانستان
الى معاقدهم في الجنوب والشرق
لم تكن هناك قوه كبيره تكفي للحاق بهم او
نزع اسلحتهم
لكنها كانت لحظه فرح عظيم لنا نحن
المجاهدين
[موسيقى]
في اقل من شهرين تمكن امراء الحرب من
استعاده نصف مساحه افغانستان انتقموا من
مقاتل طالبان برعايه الجنود الامريكيين
بعيدا عن اعين الكاميرات والناس قتل الاف
السجناء هذه الصور التي التقطت في داش
ليلي في الصحراء شمالا هي كل ما تبقى هناك
تم خنق عناصر من طالبان في حاويات شحن
معدنيه في نوفمبر 2001 وارسل اخرون الى
سجون سريه والى خليج جوانتانامو
كان مبرر الذهاب الى افغانستان هو احداث
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر لم يكن الامر يتعلق
بالقيم الاخلاقيه ولا بانقاذ النساء
الافغانيات التي تعرضنا للاضطهاد كان
الامر متعلقا بمحاوله ايجاد حكومه صديقه
وقد حققنا ذلك بسرعه
في ديسمبر 2001 تشكلت حكومه افغانيه مؤقته
بتكليف من الامم المتحده حدث ذلك بعد
ثلاثه اسابيع من استعاده كابول جنوب
البلاد كان لا يزال تحت سيطره طالبان
وكانوا في واشنطن يحتفلون بالشراكه بين
القوى الغربيه وامراء الحرب في افغانستان
[تصفيق]
الذي اختارته الولايات المتحده كان مثل
طالبان منتميا الى البشتون في جنوب
افغانستان في يوم تعيينه اعلن قبوله
استسلامهم وفي اليوم التالي السادس من
ديسمبر 2001 عقد المتحدث الرسمي باسم
طالبان مؤتمرا صحفيا
محمد عمر
ومستعدون لحل هذه المشكله بطريقه منطقيه
لكنهم للاسف لم يكونوا وقتها يصغرون
ما الذي حصل اذا بعد يوم او يومين لاذكر
السياق بدقه القرامس في الخطابا قصد منه
تحديدا الغاء اتفاق السلام ذاك
هذا ما اسميه الغلطه الاولى هؤلاء الاشخاص
سيطروا على 90% من الاراضي الافغانيه اين
ذهبوا هم لم يوقعوا اتفاقيه استسلام اي
شخص اليوم اعتقد اننا لو كنا طرحنا هذا
السؤال بجديه لجات الاجابه ان هؤلاء
الاشخاص كانوا هناك ويجب التحدث اليهم وهم
يمثلون شيئا ما فربما يمكنهم ان يكونوا
جزءا من الاجماع الوطني
الغالبيه العظمى من عناصر طالبان بالفرار
ومنهم من شق طريقه الى البلدان المجاوره
نحو مخيمات اللاجئين متراميه الاطراف
ولدت في مخيم للاجئين عندما تعرضت
افغانستان للهجوم غادر والدي مثل اخرين
كثر قبل اربع سنوات او خمس كانت الظروف في
باكستان صعبه للغايه كانت هناك قيود صارمه
على اللاجئين كنت ستتعرض للمضايقات
والتوقيف عند نقاط التفتيش وستطلب الشرطه
منك مالا لقد تلقينا معامله سيئه فعلا في
باكستان
لحالي معظم الامريكيين في ذلك الوقت
اعتقدت ان مقاتلي طالبان قد تعرضوا لضربات
محكمه وسرعان ما تم دحرهم فهربوا بسرعه
كبيره وفقدوا مصداقيتهم وانهم لن يتمكنوا
من العوده كان الاولويتنا حينها هي
القاعده
قام عشره الاف جندي امريكي وحلفائهم
بمطارده عناصر القاعده الذين اختفوا في
جبال افغانستان اختار البيت الابيض تلك
اللحظه لغزو البلاد
وافقت الامم المتحده على انشاء اكبر تحالف
عسكري هجين في التاريخ في عام 2002 ارسلت
عشرون دوله خمسه الاف جندي الى كابول
ا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عدت الى افغانستان بعد عشرين عاما كان
عمري 28 عاما تماما بدانا من الصفر وكان
علينا اعاده بناء كل شيء كل شيء بحاجه الى
اعاده اعمار البلد والمباني والطرق
والكهرباء والتعليم والانظمه الصحيه كان
لابد من اعاده بناء كل شيء وسرعان ما
ادركت ان هذا يشمل الاعلام ايضا
في عام 2004 عندما بدات العمل في شركه
الخاصه للانتاج كان علينا العمل على
الانتخابات وابلاغ الناس عنها وانتاج
اعلانات تليفزيونيه واذاعيه لاقناع الناس
بالتصويت
[ضحك]
معه
[موسيقى]
افغانستان بسم الله الرحمن
جمهوريه اسلاميه افغانستان ومن الله
التوفيق
[موسيقى]
انا
ذاهب من الله عبد الرشيد
في عام 2004 نظم المجتمع الدولي ومول
بالكامل اول انتخابات رئاسيه ديمقراطيه
لاول مره طلب منا راينا في مساله انتخاب
رئيسنا قائدنا هل حصلت على بطاقه كهذه
ذهبت مع جدي رجل تسعيني لم يقترع في حياته
لذلك رغبت ان اشاركه تلك اللحظه كانت
التجربه مفعمه بالحيويه الذهاب معا
وانتظار الدوري والتصويت
في صندوق الاقتراع خرجت من هناك وعنايه
بالدموع كما فعل كثيرون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في عام 2005 تخرجت من الجامعه وبدات العمل
كنت اجيد اللغه الانجليزيه بدا حجم العمل
يزداد كان في امكان المترجم تقاضي 200
دولار في اليوم وكان هذا مبلغا ضخما كان
الناس يجدون عملا وكانوا ايسر حالا في
البدايه كانت هناك فرص عمل كثيره
للمترجمين الفوريين ثم نهضت مختلف اعمال
البناء ووجد الناس وظائف في ذاك القطاع
بعدها نشطت المنظمات غير الحكوميه كثيرا
وافتتح المجتمع الدولي مكاتب وعاده
السفارات للعمل مره اخرى هكذا سرعان ما
وجد الاشخاص ذوي المهارات فرصا للعمل
[موسيقى]
خلال حياتنا كلها كان الحصول على علم
للبلاد حلما دائما كما تعلم يحتاج الناس
الى رموز ترفع معنوياتهم وتعززها وتشجعوهم
في هذا السياق جاء علم البلاد والجيش
الوطني والشرطه الوطنيه
وكليات البنات والبنات في المدرسه وحقوق
المراه في العمل كان هناك امل وكان
المستقبل يبدو مشرقا
[موسيقى]
ومع ذلك كانت التنميه تسير ببطء في
المناطق الريفيه ثم كما الحال الان ساد
الفقر كل ما يتذكره السكان من هذه الفتره
بالذات عسكريه واسلحه
راينا هؤلاء الاجانب يتوافدون
ولنا
هؤلاء الجنود لم يجلبوا لنا غير المعاناه
والمتاعب كنا خائفين منهم نعاني وكنا
فقراء ولم نكن سعداء
ويسببون لنا المعاناه واستمر ذلك فتره
طويله
في المناطق الريفيه المهجوره وفي مخيمات
اللاجئين وفي قاعدتهم الخلفيه داخل
باكستان حمل مقاتلون طالبان السلاح مره
اخرى
في عام 2006 سمحوا لبعض الصحفيين الغربيين
بتصويرهم وهم يقاتلون
كان علينا ان نبدا النضال من جديد انه
الجهاد في سبيل الله هذه الحرب فرضت علينا
فنحن لم نكسر باب احد لا يدعونا نعيش
بسلام في بيوتنا الفقيره كان من حقنا ان
ندافع عن وطننا وان ندافع عن امتنا
المظلومه وبحمد الله نجحنا في ذلك
الحمد لله
من سرد وسالك
اسباب منصره كنا نفتقر الى كل شيء لم تكن
لدينا اسلحه ولا معدات ولا اموال
لكننا بدانا القتال كفعل عباده لم تكن
لدينا رغبه في الراحه او في المكسب المادي
[موسيقى]
كان الناس الى جانبنا وكانت الامه باسرها
معنا قدم لنا الناس كافه انواع المساعده
جلبوا لنا الاسلحه
وجميع انواع المعدات في البدايه فزنا بدعم
القرى ثم حصلنا على دعم المقاطعات باكمله
الى طالبان وكنا بالطبع خائفات من فقدانهم
في المعارك توسلنا وبكينا
مخافه ان يصبحوا ايتاما والامهات لم ترغبن
في خساره ابنائهم ولا اخواتهن او اخوانهم
من
جهه عندما بدانا الجهاد كانت امالنا في
البقاء على قيد الحياه ضئيله اما توقعاتنا
شبه المؤكده فكانت ان موت شهداء
عندما تتقبل هذا المصير يتلاشى خوفك كله
وعندما تتخلص من الخوف يصبح كل شيء ممكنا
[تصفيق]
لم يكن الجنود الامريكيون مستعدين لمواجهه
حرب العصابات
انتقل الخوف الى الضفه الاخرى
حسبتها مهمه سهله الى حد ما واعتقدت ان
الامور قد سويت وانما كنا نفعله هناك كان
كسب وقت اضافي بهدف ايجاد طريقه لمواصله
جهودنا ضد القاعده لكن عندما نزلت الى
الميدان كان الواقع مختلفا تماما لقد وجدت
حربا حقيقيه مستمره في افغانستان على
الرغم من تصوير البيت الابيض للامر خلاف
ذلك كانت هناك حرب لم تضع وزارها بعد
كان الوضع الامني في افغانستان اخذا في
التدهور وكانت مكاسب طالبان مثيره للقلق
على نحو استثنائي
[موسيقى]
شهد الوضع تدهورا كبيرا وملحوظا في عام
2007 وبدون شك فان استخدام قوه قتاليه
اضافيه من النيتو ومن الولايات المتحده
سيكون ضروريا لعكس زخم طالبان
في غضون عامين فقط تضاعف عدد الجنود
الامريكيين والغربيين وبحلول عام 2008 كان
هناك 60 الف جندي من اربعين دوله مختلفه
وكلما زاد عدد الجنود المنتشرين في
افغانستان ازدادت ضراوه قتال طالبان
كانت مناطق القتال شاسعه وكانت نائيه
للغايه تلقى الفرنسيون بعض الضربات وحدثت
في صفوفهم اصابات كل خطوه الى الامام قمنا
بها كانت مهمه بالنسبه اليهم
كنتم تهاجموننا وكنا نرد على هجماتكم كنا
اعدائكم
كانت طالبان اكثر فاعليه مما دفع الناس
الى تصديقه هؤلاء الرجال يعيدون بناء
انفسهم وهم فعالونا في عدد البناء تلك
الطريقه التي تدربنا بها وتحليلي الشخصي
جعلاني اقتنع انهم كانوا حلفاء للقاعده
متشابكين معها الى ابعد الحدود
ثم وجدت في وقت لاحق ان هذا ليس صحيحا
فطالبان اقرب بكثير الى المقاومه الفرنسيه
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه من نواحي عده
لانهم كيان مناطقي يتالف من البشتون
اليوم بعد 14 عاما تتناثر الجروح المفتوحه
فوق المناظر الطبيعيه جنوب افغانستان حتى
المدارس القليله لم تسلم من القصف
هذه الندوب خلفتها الضربات التي عانى منها
المحاصرون بين النيران المتبادله في لعبه
السلطه تلك
مطربا لنا مشاكل عند نقاط التفتيش اخبرونا
ان منازلنا سوف تقصد ثم طردون منها ولم
يسمحوا لنا باخذ اي شيء واستخدموها
ثم جاءت الطائرات وقصفتها قلوبنا كانت
ترتجف خوفا عند سماع عزيز الطائرات
الاطفال وركضوا الى الداخل للاختباء عندما
بدا قصف الطائرات في الليل افقنا مرعوبين
كنا نلتصق بالجدران ونختبئ في الخزائن بعد
ذلك نمنا واحذيتنا تحت وسائدنا
صور الانتصارات في محيط المدينه كانت
مضلله كانوا فقط يتسترون على حرب اخرى
تخاد من اجل السلطه وامتلاكها
استعاد امراء الحرب اماكنهم نتيجه تزوير
الانتخابات على نطاق واسع كانت المحسوبيه
متفشيه
وحتى البرلمان كان انعكاسا لحال البلد كان
منقسما
[موسيقى]
كانت تركيبه تجمع امراء الحرب وامراء
المخدرات والفاسدين والطيبين والتكنوقرات
والشيوعيين واليسار واليمين والوسط من
جميع انواع الناس من الشعبويين بعض
المحتالين والمجرمين راوا ذلك فقالوا هذا
سيجلب لنا الكثير من المال حتى ان بعض
زملائي في ذلك البرلمان جانو الكثير من
المال لقد وجد الفساد نافذه هناك وتشكلت
مافيا سياسيه برعايه المافيا الاقتصاديه
هدفق المال السريع والسهل من المخدرات
تغير المشهد الحضري في كابول
بدات قصور الخشخاش في الظهور في العام
2007 وكانت المثال على عماره نهضت باموال
المخدرات
في الزوايا المظلمه احدثت المخدرات دمرا
كبيرا
وتصدرت افغانستان الانتاج العالمي للافيون
والهيروين
في البدايه كان هناك كيف تسميه تسامح الى
ان هذه الامور سوف تعالج لاحقا دعونا نضع
حكما قانونيا موضع التنفيذ دعونا نضع
التنميه موضع التنفيذ دعونا نبني قدرات
الحكومه وسوف تتموضع السياسات المحليه
تلقائيا لكن ذلك كان سوء تقدير ولم تكن
تلك الطريقه الصحيحه لتسيير الامور امراء
الحرب هؤلاء توقعوا المقابل من الفئات
الاكثر هشاشه وتسارع للوصول الى تلك
المكاسب الجزء الاكبر من ارباح المخدرات
لن يذهب الى المتمردين 150 مليون دولار
تذهب للمتمردين لكن لمن يذهب المليار
والثمانمائه مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
هذه المبالغ كانت سخيفه مقارنه بتلك التي
ضخها الغرب في البلاد
كانت الجمهوريه الفاتيه خامس افقر دوله في
العالم تتلقى جرعات دعم هائله قيمتها مئات
المليارات من الدولارات
مبالغ مخصصه لبناء الطرق والمباني العامه
والتدريب والامدادات
كان الاقتصاد الافغاني فقاعه وجزء كبير من
هذا التمويل خرج من البلاد مباشره الى
خزائن الشركات الدوليه ومقاوليها من
الباطن
تدفع ريشا تصب في جيوب الوزير لمنح عقد ما
لكن الاسوا من ذلك كان ذهاب 50% من قيمه
العقود الى الشركات التي تتقاضى اصلا
تكاليف فضائحيه لقاء اعمال الاداره او
الاشراف كان لديك اشخاص يقولون معك مئه
لتنفقها انفقها بسرعه لاننا ننتظر رؤيه
النتائج كانوا ينفقون مئه للحصول على
نتيجه تكلف 30 مثل سد صغير او طريق او
مدرسه حيث كانت الثلاثون كافيه لكن تقرير
كان سيقول ان الحصول على هذه النتيجه يكلف
100 مليون
توقفوا عن لوم قدرات الافغان فالتخطيط
الضعيف والمانحون هم المسؤولون عن ذلك على
سبيل المثال قد تنفق الجهه المانحه او تضع
في الميزانيه 200 مليون دولار لمشروع ما
كانوا يعلمون انه يمكن انفاقها على مدى
اربع سنوات لكن كما تعلمون هناك عاده
اغراق الميزانيه بكل شيء وفي السنه الاولى
لانه بالنسبه لبعض المانحين في نهايه
اليوم سيعلنون ذلك في بلدانهم ومن المهم
اظهار مقدار الاموال التي صرفوها
عندما وصل هذا الفساد الى اعلى مراتب
الدوله بدات الامور تتدهور بشكل خطير
فعندما ادرك الصغار وهم لم يكونوا
بالضروره من الفاسدين ان الفساد كان على
نطاق واسع ونحن هنا نتحدث عن مبالغ ضخمه
قالوا لانفسهم لما لا نفعل ذلك وهكذا
انتشر الفساد في الهرم باكمله
كانت الحكومه الافغانيه تفقد كل مصداقيه
كان مقاتل طالبان يتقدمون فخلال 30 عاما
من وجودها لم تغير الحركه من استراتيجيتها
في الايام الاولى عودوا عن تقصير الدوله
ثم حصلوا على دعم الشعب من خلال استعاده
النظام وتطبيق احكام الشريعه
[موسيقى]
كانت وزاره العدل لدينا دقيقه للغايه حتى
من المدن التي كان فيها وجود للحكومه
اعتاد الناس ان ياتوا الينا لعرض مشاكلهم
لانهم كانوا يؤمنون بان القضاء في الاماره
سوف يحل تلك المشاكل بدون رشوه وبدون طلب
للمال ادعوا
سبب انتصار الاماره كان توافقنا واتحادنا
كانت لنا ثقه في قادتنا لم يكن همنا
السلطه والمناصب بامارات وعندما تم تعيين
رجال معينين حكاما للمناطق لم يعترض احد
على ذلك
لن اجيب على الاسئله السياسيه حول اسباب
الجهاد وحيثياته
الحمد لله الحمد لله قادتنا يتعاملون مع
هذه المسائل جميعها
كل شيء يوضع وفق الشريعه الاسلاميه ويتم
تنفيذه على هذا الاساس ايا كانت التعليمات
التي تصلنا منهم فاننا نطبقها وفقا
للاسلام والشريعه الاسلاميه
حكومتهم لم تستطع القيام بذلك كانوا
عاجزين كانت حكومه دميه كل السلطه كانت في
ايدي الاخرين لم يتمكنوا من فعل شيء